i am obviously a huge fan of james
cameron
and avatar uh i love the way that he
basically pushes technology forward in
all of his movies in a way that no one
sees coming
can you sort of talk about what it's
like collaborating with him
on these upcoming films and maybe how to
how he's pushing
technology again yeah he's definitely
pushing it
big time on this one and i'm not i'm not
giving away any trade secrets to say
that
but i remember working on a sequence
with him which he which was had there
was a scale
an issue of scale going on okay
and and it was defeating it was just
it sort of brought everything to kind of
a halt
there was a problem that no one else
recognized
except him at the moment and so he had
to come up with a solution
anyway we basically shut down or started
working on something else because yeah
the next day he came to me
kind of you know real excited and said i
figured out the algorithm
to do this and and he he stated this
algorithm and i'm looking at him
thinking
what the hell are you talking about i
have no idea
even what you're talking about but he
did he he
he he he created a problem because he
because he want he
there was a problem because he wanted a
scene something to happen
and then he solved it he's been doing
that for his entire career
and it's really it's pretty cool pretty
amazing if you don't mind me asking and
i don't want to get you in any trouble
but what was it like reading those
scripts for the first time
what what did you take away from i don't
know if you've read all four at the same
time or just one of them
but could you sort of talk about that
when i finished the last script
i i was uh weeping i just thought it was
so
beautiful yeah the the final script
because because he told he's he's
telling a great great story
an original story a beautiful beautiful
story
and uh um i was just incredibly
you know moved by it and i hope and i
trust and believe that
audiences will be too because one of the
things that he does
really really well is he takes he moves
it from the page to the stage
in a very very way in a way
that that you is very literal you know
what i mean you you really see it what
you what just what you read is what you
get
from him i think you know and more